I'm not full hoarder but there's certain
things that I've like asso this room
coming after hoarders would be a big big
swing I kind I'm like looking at there's
a lot going on there's a lot of details
in here but it it's also a set so yeah
yeah it's for it's in my home this is my
I do sleep in here there's a horse thing
going on yeah but it's like you can't
there's something that happens when I
don't know if it's like Terror
management Theory like which is like the
idea that we know that we're going to
die so we have to start collecting
things to feel a sense of permanence or
something you cheer for teams you pick a
play like some to make you feel like
you're not GNA die or like will have
some kind of lasting effect who know
that's why people like like trophies and
plaques and family crests and like that
there's a point where you're just like I
have six horse things like I mean I also
have OCD but I'm like I like I have to
have this one so this one like has a
friend and then it just turns into like
I can't not buy it it's like guys
looking at butts you're just like let me
just I know I'm going to look I have to
just look at it and then I can stop
looking at it is that what it is hor
vintage hor stuff for me is like guys
looking at women's butts it's not like
sure you you're just like there it is
moving on right you know what I
mean I'm trying to think if that's how I
look at
butts well you live in Portland all the
women are like lesbians in burlap like
everybody everybody's got butts everyone
in Portland just like dresses like a a
janitor and a Broadway play for no
reason like a fisherman I like how the
Broadway play went could stop a janitor
but like but there's theatrics to it
right there is you're kind of like
that's a brand new pair of aged vintage
jeans I think there there is that
there's the stereotypes of it but then
there's also just it's a city it's got
everything you want you spent a lot of
time defending Portland I feel like yeah
I just bought a house there I
got I made myself a permanent part of
the community I got you got to be on
board come on we're in La at least the
butts are real up there I what like in
Venice yesterday I saw a woman that was
shaped I'm like you're anime you're not
real what is that you're you're a
hologram it's a it's a well-shaped
hologram but no nothing about you looks
like you are comfortable with what
you've done to
yourself it does look like the all the
women I feel like look the same to me I
don't know if it's the contouring makeup
or what it is oh yeah the contouring and
the body is like I don't know I fake boo
my is well I mean again I've got stupid
tattoos but they' made me feel better
when I got them if it makes you feel
better to get it than feel better I do
not think I could ever date a guy
without
tattoos oh really I look at somebody
without tattoos now I'm like wow you
made it I feel like if I see a guy
without tattoos my brain is just like do
you not care believe in anything like do
like you think they believe in
themselves I think is what's going on
with somebody without tattoos like oh I
actually like who I am well enough to
not ruin it tattoos are like an old dog
you don't like that won't die like this
is just around now I got to get used to
this thing I love what what which ones
don't you like they're all stupid I like
the palm trees that was there's an alien
landing on a beach I love that UFO this
is a it's a grim reaper it says party
pooper and it's that's a cover up cuz I
thought the other tattoo was
dumb what was the other one it was a
clock with
wings which I got when I was 20 time get
it it was like may as well just get
popsicle stick jokes tattooed all over
this one says whoops that's
funny that's good good conversation I
got that that's that old one too man and
then are they all over you or just your
arms arms and then I got my one leg with
a bunch of silly what I got like Jesus
with Bob Seager lyrics oh that's cool
rambling Gambling Man I did a I put a
pentagram underneath that cuz I had to
balance some God and
Devil
I got I got the pig from uh from the
pork chop Express from Big Trouble in
Little China shut the kind of invincible
underneath
it or over it I don't remember I don't
look at them and like how did you like
how old were you when you got like what
was the process of going through that
there's all these tattoos that I want
and I'm kind of like I get like 70%
there and I'm curious the other 30% see
this is where I got I got in trouble for
saying this a while ago I think I was on
hot ones and it was before Anthony
Bourdain took took an exit but I was I
was talking about his tattoos I'm like
he got them all within like one year
like a new Suicide Girl and
then that joke didn't age well or
whatever but yeah when you see somebody
gets one and then within like 18 months
they just got it done like there's
nothing interesting about like a themed
sleeve like all it says like good you
could sit still for a while like I want
to individual like oh this one I got
with my buddy and we were doing this and
then this one I that was a crazy night
like that's the story I'd rather see
with the tattoos and something silly and
funny I do like somebody that like oh
they didn't take it too seriously but
they like it's the universe sure it is
dude that's the arm you beat off with
who
cares yeah I guess I just I feel kind of
like not having I have white tattoos and
then I have like one or two over here
but I feel very um you have white
tattoos yeah they use white ink so see
right there so that like it's kind of a
non-committal it just sums me up in a
nutshell tattoo but not at all poser
yeah it's just like I I don't want to
commit to it does it stay it's just for
me yeah can you not see like that one
right there I see it oh cuz it look kind
of looks like a scar yeah that it's what
it is it's basically like
a CH H 10 times as much and no one can
see it but hurt hurt worse than hitting
your arm on that
chair by the way I did it over here too
and I think I was able to I think it's
when you closed your eyes cuz we had a
real moment I was like I I don't know
why I'm struggling with this chair I
think I'm nervous around you